[Music]
yeah
breaking a spare shaft with a shield
would that work probably not you can cut
through a spear shaft but it takes
several blows with a sharp sword it's
not a lightsaber hi I'm Matt Easton hi
I'm Toby capwell
my name is Jim Ken hi my name is Shane
Adams the owner of the Knights of Valor
my name is David rolling of the London
long sword Academy my name is Jamie
yankovitz So today we're going to be
looking at some pole arm combat scenes
horseback fighting medieval arms and
armor nunchuck scenes
we're going to be looking at some
archery scenes from TV and film and
seeing how kind of realistic they are
[Music]
he's got what we call a cant on the bow
there I tend to shoot with a with a
little bit of a cant it opens up the
site windows up if your bows up Straight
Like That
generally the thing you're trying to
shoot is going to be hidden by the bow
so I tend to drop the the bow out of the
way a little bit which is what he's
doing he's clearly pointing one way but
you can see the arrow on his hand
pointing the other way and a lot of
people call that the Arches Paradox The
Arches Paradox is the fact that the
arrow is pointing off to the to the left
when you're actually pointing at the the
target at the right that's the Paradox
and it's the flexing of the arrow that
that makes it uh travel downrange
could I kill this dude running away
distance I'm only really accurate up to
uh probably about 30 meters I'd get him
eventually see I'd be zigging and
zagging I'd be I'd be Serpentine and
there is a type of archery called a
clout typically done by English Longbow
arches which is long distance shooting
um where you shoot at a flag in the
ground sort of you know 180 200 yards
away shooting up shooting down closest
to the flag so there are people that can
shoot very very well at long long range
medieval Longbow archers were you know
could be pretty accurate the bow looked
like it had what they call Pony limbs
where you've got the basic bow and then
you'd have another set of Limbs that
come off the front so that limb is
attached to that Limb and that limb is
attached to that Limb and that gives you
way more power so it would be perfect
for that kind of you know
killing dudes running away kind of
archery I'm going to give him a nine for
Game of Thrones I think
[Music]
compound bow is typically sort of either
a Target style or a hunting bow you can
you basically you can adjust the angle
that the limbs are at uh and if you wind
them in it gives you a little bit more
power and I think what he's doing there
is maximizing his power on his compound
bow
now you can buy arrows that come in
parts that's not how arrows work that's
that's just asking for trouble there are
points in an arrow that that flex and if
you are cutting an arrow into three and
assembling it it's not going to behave
like it should now
that there that's that's John Rambo's
grenade tipped Arrow there was a type of
Broadhead you could buy and it came in a
case like that I think that's just the
case of a Broadhead sprayed bronze
[Music]
left-handed so that's okay but I know it
later on he shoots he shoots it
right-handed the arrow flight on that is
is utter garbage maybe he's shooting
okay he's shooting a compound off his
fingers which is which is fine compounds
tend to use a release Aid which gives
you a much straighter release well I
mean this type of bow the further you
pull it back the higher the poundage
gets a compound bow starts high and gets
lighter so you can hold it at full draw
for long periods of time a little bit
more sort of fast a bit more powerful
grenade tipped Arrow yeah they do exist
whether or not they're commercially
available I I don't know everything else
look really good the way he was setting
up the bow the way he was changing his
poundage and everything I like that and
the fact that he shot the arrow it flew
like garbage but if you you know got a
Grenade sitting on the end of The Arrow
it probably would fly like that so
weirdly I think it's probably quite
realistic I'm going to give Rambo an
eight
[Music]
there's a huge tennis ball on the end of
her Arrow the more weight you put on the
front of an arrow the the less efficient
it's going to be it's just not going to
go very far let me just fix this give me
a second
yeah
is it a little Grabber or something on
the end of that Arrow again that's going
to add even more weight it's not a case
of one Arrow fits all uh arrows come in
spine weights and that refers to the
stiffness of the arrow and obviously
certain bows need a certain spine weight
so the higher the poundage the bow the
stiffer the arrow needs to be and vice
versa so by adding a lot of weight to
the front of the arrow you dynamically
weaken the spine of the arrow so
therefore the arrow would be out spine
and it would probably just Veer off to
the to the right and not hit the bell at
all you can shoot something called a
blunt which is a flat Arrow Head which
would be for
either stump shooting shooting tin cans
you know that kind of thing or small
game hunting
she's moving her arm up
and when you're shooting at distance
whether it's it's low down or high up
you don't really move your arm you you
move from the waist so you kind of pivot
your whole body not just your arm up and
down that's something I I just spotted
[Music]
oh the shot itself not very realistic at
all
but her shooting is is pretty good we'll
go five five out of ten in the middle
you've got really long arrows there it
looks like she's only using two fingers
on the string one above one below I've
seen people do that
she's got quite a quite an overdraw
there she's got this explosive release
which again in order to make a good
archery shot you need to keep it concise
and simple because something like that
you're not going to be able to repeat it
time and time again if you've got a
simple release that comes back you can
repeat that
you've got to be safe with everything
you film and I imagine that bow is
probably a very real bow but it was
probably such low poundage and had such
a stretchy string that it goes straight
back to being a straight piece of wood
the distance
between the the lowest point of the bow
and the string that's called the brace
height if your brace height is too low
your bow becomes very noisy it becomes
quite quick but it becomes very noisy
and you're really really in danger of
getting some real nasty string burn on
your on your arm
shooting multiple arrows off a bow at
the same time what happens is because
you've got all the energy comes from
from the limbs and pulling the string
back and what that does it pushes the
arrow forward and the heavier the arrow
that it needs to push the more energy it
needs to to sort of get that Arrow to
where it needs to go but if you're
shooting multiple arrows essentially the
bow doesn't know there's multiple arrows
on there it just thinks there's a really
heavy Arrow two arrows is double the
weight you know and the more arrows you
put on the the heavier weight that bow
is going to need to push push the arrows
through the air and it basically just
takes all the guts out the boat we'll
give Wonder Woman a five they did all
right
rest
in order to shoot well you need to be
able to move so I think the fact that
they've got her in a tight thing and she
can't chew properly I think it's
brilliant
archery is all about keeping everything
straight the less influence you can have
over the bow the better the arrow is
going to fly so if you're influencing
the shot the shot's not gonna go right
so if you can keep everything nice and
simple what she's doing she's coming
back on the same plane as the arrows
going forward
archery is all about being able to
repeat the shot time and time again
there's a famous book called The Art of
repetition which is all about archery
and if you can replicate your shot time
and time again you will be a fantastic
Archer she seems to have a nice
repeatable kind of form there
look at look at this loose the trick is
with archery is you don't let go of the
string the trick is to try and no longer
be holding the string so you've got to
relax your hand let the hand flow back
if you're kind of trying to open your
hand as as hard as you can you'll never
beat the string the string is going to
be quicker than your reactions across
the board so if you can just just get to
your Anchor Point and then relax your
hand and let it come back you're going
to get a much smoother release and you
can see your hand just just relaxes
a lot of people think Arrows fly
straight they don't if you watch an
arrow in slow motion it's like a wet
noodle uh going down range
which is Robin hooded and arrow which is
where you shoot an arrow down the back
of another arrow and the grain tends to
split but the grain never runs perfectly
parallel down the back of an arrow it
will always kind of peel off it's
actually really hard to do with wood
Narrows so it's a lot easier to do with
with sort of modern one arrows because
they're a tube of carbon and and it's
easier to kind of putting an arrow down
the back of another one that's ten one
of the best representations of the way
uh an arrow and a bow work together
trying to work out what bow that is
obviously it's got some gadgets on it it
could be a modified Hoyt Buffalo
spray black he's using a finger and
thumb drawer which which isn't really
necessarily gonna going to work for that
kind of thing Hawk has a bit of a mess
dude he's got a shooting glove which is
good to see actually got a couple of arm
guards on there as well that's what's
called a biter arm guy that's just a
make of arm guard thin strip of plastic
and it just protects you from the from
the the sort of the string as as it sort
of vibrates back to to where it's
supposed to go sometimes it can just
catch your arm
um let me just give you a little sting
so you tend to have a little bit of an
arm guard who just protects you
traditional arches tend to wear like a
bit more of a leather kind of bracer you
wouldn't wear too unless you're doing
something really wrong well they can't
bank with a dam
if you can't look at it how are you
going to shoot it the trend with these
kind of dynamic things is is that
there's never any kind of Anchor Point
it's always just
pull it back and let it go from whatever
position you're in which which is fine
but you're not going to get that kind of
level of accuracy that he gets like he's
he's shooting moving targets now there
is a famous trick shot but you're
looking in a mirror and I've tried it
and I'm
almost succeeded
[Music]
he's got what maybe
36 arrows maximum when he first starts
it's like films with guns you get people
shooting
and they never seem to have to reload
but it looks like it's fun so I'm gonna
have to give it four
okay
come on people can
um knock arrows out of the air it's not
something I would recommend trying
because if you get it wrong you only get
one chance I want people to enjoy
archery but I also want people to be
really safe when it comes to archery
there's a huge safety element to it
although a bow isn't classed as a weapon
it's classed as Sporting Goods
it can be used as a weapon they're
shooting arrows at the guy and he's
knocking them out the air I'd hate for
some kids to think hey let's try that
and and do it and get her it will break
my heart
try the other side
I'll save you a second on the reload
foreign he gets to show him a different
way of shooting now this this all came
from Lars Anderson video that came out a
few years back and it kind of turned the
archery World on his head and he
suggested that you took the arrow from
the left side of the bow to the right
side of the bow which which goes from
essentially a a western style of archery
to an Eastern style of archery changing
anything in archery is a slow process
takes time for your body to get used to
such a change and going from from one
side of the
bow to the other it would take time
[Music]
shoot the arrow on the right side of the
bow with a Mediterranean release one
finger above the arrow two fingers below
what happens is the arrow V is wildly
off uh to the right which is an ideal
and there are people that can shoot a
Mediterranean style release like like
the way they get Robin Hood to do in
this film I've got to pull pull the bow
out this way if you're doing big Dynamic
movements to try and get the arrow to go
straight they're very difficult to
repeat so you're not going to be
fantastically accurate with them is
there something that I personally I'm
not a huge fan of there are people that
shoot hybrid style sort of east and west
at the end of the day you've got to
shoot in a way that you've that's
comfortable and that puts the biggest
smile on your face
because it does require a certain amount
of Fitness certain amount of stamina to
shoot because it's that you know they're
they're not easy to pull back and you've
got to hold sometimes tremendous weights
for
you know a good few seconds before you
make the shot you know various lifting
weights isn't necessarily going to work
the archery muscles
that is actually a good archery muscle
is working there that's going to do more
for him than bench pressing Wheels you
can use stretchy bands things like that
that sort of builds up muscles and and
whatnot see I want to give a really low
score but I like the working out with
the with the ropes so I'm going to push
it up I'm going to give it a full
she's using sound to make a deer move
into a more accessible shot which is
fine but I would imagine a deer would
have just bolted at that stage there you
know from my experience they're pretty
skittish things what are you gonna do
with that when you kill it
I like it personally when you're at full
draw you come you come to Anchor and
you're there you know if you're doing
all this the shot's gone you need to
have Focus she actually has beautiful
form in this film and she was coached by
an Olympic Archer called the katuna
loric an American Olympic Archer again a
fantastic Archer so her form is is an
Olympic form which is which is fantastic
for target archery now she's in a
hunting scenario that type of archery
isn't necessarily going to work
fantastically well in this sort of
scenario
there's so many variables you're uphill
you're downhill there's there's you're
waiting at full draw for something to to
come into to shop
she's doing a bit of wing shooting there
she's shooting a bird shooting a moving
Target is also difficult
um and you wouldn't be able to to use an
Olympic style of shooting to shoot a
moving Target
now they look like a huge plastic
feathers
um and she's shooting off the shelf
that's not necessarily going to work out
too well the sort of bow she's got there
is is not Million Miles Away from from
this type of bow that's called a shelf
so the arrow sits sits on there and as
the arrow passes over the reason why uh
traditional archers use feathers is
because they compress and they don't
really cause too much of an issue where
if you're shooting plastic feathers like
those that they're not going to compress
like a feather wood and that's going to
that's going to cause some fouling on
the on the Shelf
yeah
shooting a Broadhead which is a hunting
Arrow it's a two-bladed Broadhead and
it's stuck into the target quite
realistically that's kind of how a
Broadhead would stick into a hard target
even a light poundage bow would probably
do that it's not hard wired into the
pig's mouth or anything it was just
resting there so I don't think it would
take it take a huge amount I mean I've
tried to shoot apples before
um and what tends to happen is the arrow
just goes straight through the the Apple
so you knock it off whatever you're
shooting but I I I've yet to pin one to
a wall the type of archery I do it's
called instinctive archery is I don't
use a sight and I let my my mind and my
brain and my muscle memory work
subconsciously
to let me know where to shoot that's
what she's doing there I would imagine
she's she's although she's got a very
limpic style where she's looking at
something and she's just bang and and
she nailed it I've always got a soft
spot for The Hunger Games do you know
I'm gonna give it seven
the whole battery of archers is gonna is
gonna really mess some Orcs up which is
which is what's happening there I can't
see the types of Arrow points they're
using but I I've seen a lot of films
people using broadheads and shooting at
Armor and that wouldn't work there were
certain Arrow points that were designed
to go straight through armor like a
Bodkin it's pointy but it's bulbous and
it's stiffer and it was designed to kind
of punch through armor
his elbow is a bit High but you know
I'll give him that when you've got some
big orc dude with a stick coming at you
you're not always gonna get a chance to
set and make the perfect shot but in
order to speed shoot to that kind of
level
you'd need a pretty light poundage bow
I'm gonna go four but it's cool
this is more of an Eastern style his
arrow is really short
and it's actually he's got like a piece
of bamboo on the Arrow attached to the
bow where the short Arrow will because
obviously the longer the arrow the
heavier the shorter the arrow the
lighter the lighter something is the
further it's going to go the faster it's
going to go so it means you can pull the
bow back all the way and put maximum
maximum juice into that little arrow
he's using his thumb uh typically the
you over you over draw with that style
of archery you relax that hand and come
away from the thumb and let the string
you can see the focus in his face
breathing is is a weird one some people
hold their breath some people breathe
through the shot if you're hunting uh
and and you're waiting for a deer to
sort of come interview you could be
holding for a a good 10 15 20 seconds
Olympic arches
um tend to hold for a lot longer some
people are even even quicker some people
come to full draw and then make the shot
I guess if you can't drop him straight
away you can you can wound him and then
I'm gonna chase him down and
poking with something else obviously if
there was a Barb on it you couldn't pull
it out you'd kind of have to pull it
through which I manually would be Agony
that to me looked like a sharpened stick
so yeah you could probably pull that out
medieval arches used to do
um when they put their Arrow points on
they would put them on with
um wax if they hit you I pull it out the
the the point's still in you or if you
missed it landed on the floor the point
would come off so it couldn't be then be
shot back at you but weirdly archers
nowadays are more likely to be injured
by the knock end than the the pointy end
because when that's in the target people
walk up and stumble and things and that
can be quite sharp I'm gonna give that
one nine hey there my name's David
rolling of the London long sword Academy
I'm a full-time swordsmanship instructor
and today I'm going to have a look at a
load of clips about sword fighting and
slack them off hideously
so basically what I have with me here is
a long sword long sword for me is
generally a sword which is held in two
hands so it doesn't matter whether the
grip is short or long it doesn't really
matter you have a pommel a cross card a
grip a blade usually within fencing we
divide that into two halves but
different authors divide it into
different different divisions so we'll
have a strong half which is the half
from the middle to the hilt and then
from the middle down to the point is the
weakest part and we're just really
looking at geometry and Leverage
that you get this big thing in
historical European martial arts as I do
but you're not allowed to carry swords
on your shoulder because that's really
really frowned upon and no one would
ever do it except there's actually
critique in manual saying that you
shouldn't do it which implies that
people do do it so carrying the sword in
your hand is a very very good thing and
you see this a lot people holding a
sword on their shoulder and just walking
around with it without a Scabbard on
necessarily so it's ready to use
I have issues with this particular fight
because there's a lot of reverse grip
with the sword being held backwards down
here it's not a good way for you to use
the sword you sacrifice your ability to
defend above very very clearly you have
not got any reach it's not safe
how do you change grip yay oh and he's
back
I like how he moves I think he's got a
good organic feel to him generally the
sword is being moved in front of him
which is a very very good thing it's
very rarely just kept behind him so he's
closing the space off between him and
his opponent with the sword
one of the things I like about some of
the witcher's fight scenes is that there
is this idea of moving between the
opponents and you see this in things
like godino where the idea of spinning
something which people really really
quite often frown upon within the Hema
Community is very much used because
you're trying to keep opponents away
from each other so it's not just about
fighting you and concentrate and moving
into you it's against driving you back
and then hitting the next person the
next person the next person so these
spinning moves actually become quite
important and this angled Sinister
Straight Into You idea goes out the
window it's not this focused suddenly
it's much more wide and it's a flurry
the thing is is most of my judgment on
this fight the fight scene is actually
Henry Cavill being very very good
physically and what is shown in this
fight scene being probably the most
disappointing fight scene in The Witcher
so for Henry Cavill it's going to have
like an eight for actual quality of
fighting it's going to have about four
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so there's bits in there that actually
aren't too bad looking at it there's
evasions of the blade from the emperor
which could be accidental but you have
these movements of just moving around as
the as the Paris coming in that's
actually not too bad you see this kind
of thing quite often you see in distress
when opponents are moving around each
other where a Parry comes in you
disengage underneath as it's happening
so you have potential for some actually
quite interesting movements in there
foreign
good Parry you see that Intel Hoffer
usually accompanied by a wrap because of
the closure in the close distance
kicking up the heels is referred to in
quite a few treaties quite often
accompanied by a movement onto the jaw
as well so potentially within this fight
scene I'd say in those last two actions
from the cover to the uh to the kick
with the legs the sweeping up of the
heels I'd say those are actually quite
good actions usually you'd see more
control of the opponent's weapon arm or
their balance with the offhand as well
but that part's actually reasonably good
so for that I'm actually going to give
it a six because I think those two
aspects save it slightly
[Music]
yeah
okay so again we've got some very very
good bits on this the first bit of this
is the the shunting away of the opponent
I really really like this he creates
distance between the two opponents now
you could argue that maybe he'd want to
push the opponents into each other but
he he has a very very good instinctive
response push one away get the weapon
from it and then on to the other one and
then a good clean finish on one of the
cuts nothing Posh just as simple cut a
wrath in effect pretty good
I'd give that a seven I think that's
quite a comfortable thing again I think
it's very easy within uh judging this
from a human's perspective to get very
focused on an individual and this is
showing good awareness of space
maintaining that distance and then
simple finishes nothing posh
[Music]
so immediately the first attack is this
big Spa I'll spin at you I'll expose my
back and
the distance is so bad that he could
just be stabbed in the back
yeah it's it's a broadsword or or a
saber or something therefore you have to
go and cut candles or scenery you don't
use this like this this is terrible
foreign
in Japanese swordsmanship you're moving
the glass deposits the slab deposits of
actually silicon deposits that can be in
steel you're moving those throughout the
entirety of the length of the blade and
through those foldings you basically you
spread that out so you make sure that
your blade hasn't got one particular
area of weakness now with European
swords before we had that consistency we
did something very similar except that
we Twisted them like string so that if
one thread was weak then that's
necessary could be a problem in itself
but you're having multiple threads and
twisting them around each other you
create something stronger but that said
swords do snap swords do Bend and
there's always a fine point and you
can't guarantee the process is not
perfect even nowadays with much more
clear definitions of how steel should be
made and produced blade still break so
it's not impossible for this to happen
so this is where it really gets quite
terrible there's this
insane idea that somehow long swords are
really heavy clumsy weapons they are not
you can move a long sword much more
quickly and much more dexterously than
you can a rape here it still balanced as
if to be used in one hand but you have
the advantage of being able to move it
around this position the position of the
forward hand now even the most barbaric
moment of a long sort of barbaric
Technique we have a technique called the
strike of Wrath which is a strike that
uses the entirety of the anterior
oblique slings that's the most powerful
strike you can do but it's not done
foolishly it's done as a mechanic it's a
way of claiming space in front of you
claiming that space for yourself killing
with it if you can and then going on to
pursue your opponent through that wide
swings don't serve anybody and they
represent the actual piece of equipment
very very poorly
doing a spin when you're not engaged
with the opponent's blade is insane
because you don't know what their sword
is doing and because you're so close and
you don't know where that sword is
obviously they can cut you freely
because they're still facing at you they
still have all of their requisite safety
in their hands
three four out of ten
this in case you didn't know it is the
best fight scene ever in any film ever
the fencing in it is completely
irrelevant the fencing is part of a
narrative device it's not meant to
overwhelm you it's just there happening
while the dialogue does
[Music]
I thought of fitting considering the
rocky terrain there's references to
benetti's defense I don't even know and
you know what that is but references to
Tebow and Tebow is one of my favorite
systems but they're not showing any
awareness of Tebow Tebow operates on the
idea of the perfect angle that you see
in a lot of Spanish swordsmanship and
distress are particularly here where you
have a 90 degree angle which is
maintained as much as possible and you
don't make lateral movements with your
arms but all of this is what we call
vulgar angles where the point is higher
than the hilt and lots of lateral
movement naturally you must expect me to
attack
naturally
Rapier some people call it a side sword
the divisions are really a later thing
we don't worry about it too much it's a
sword that you hold in one hand now
again we have the equivalence quite
often or could be just like the cross
guard in effect quite often people would
hold this simply like so without their
finger over the bars and these extra
Rings would be to stop things from
landing on your fingers when you're
holding the sword normally and this
allows you to put your thumb on there
later on you start seeing people holding
the sword like so okay but it's not
Universal sometimes it is just use like
this okay sometimes these are very very
ornate as you can see here there's a lot
of wire around here and then sometimes
it's just a simple cup there's something
I want to tell you tell me
I'm not left-handed either
the idea of being able to fence with
both hands shouldn't be necessarily a
problem
um fighting somebody who is differently
handed to you as well shouldn't be an
uncommon experience so this this kind of
thing although it's amusing you don't
want to do this sort of thing at close
distance because obviously while you're
busy changing your sword hand your
opponent can stab you and this kind of
thing here you have a bit whereas the
blade comes through it disengages so
you're having the blade changing from
one side to the other and in order to
fight that what you're doing is rather
than doing lateral powers like this
you're wrapping the blade and you're
staying engaged to it and that can be
used to throw the opponent sword out
their hands so there's there's a degree
of reality in that it's good
technically wise I'd still give it sort
of like a six seven even with its parody
fencing it still has better fencing than
um than a lot of the others
that's quite nice because in effect you
have a very very nasty version of a
movement of conclusion this is basically
where in using a sword to Parry here we
then do something with the offhand if we
were to inverted there the idea would be
to restrain the opponent's weapon hand
so it can control it and we can choose
whether they live or die and we can show
Mercy at this point if you're doing this
this is lovely he doesn't have to worry
about the guys offhand so much because
the guy has both hands on the sword
there's a closure off of the line and
the guy giving him the distance because
he doesn't have to move his feet the
guy's going to come and hit him anyway
he gets to push it aside he gets to
thrust through he's got control of the
opponent's sword still and he gets to
finish him so that I actually quite like
that's pretty good
I'm not entirely sure holding your hand
Palm down with the longsword is a good
way not to get the sword taken oh my
goodness this is terrible
there is so much bad in this again we're
back on this idea that if you've got a
long sword you have to do this with it
and it has to be wide and spinny and it
has to be these big moves it's meant to
be dexterous you have this idea that
there's basically half an hour the idea
of being this kind of space here rather
halfway between here and here you don't
want to be more than this way far away
from your opponent with the points at
all times so if they drive you away
you're trying to find a way to get your
point onto them most long sword is
intrinsically trying to dominate a space
very very close into the core of your
opponent if they move you sufficiently
around you're immediately back at
another opening if they stay tight on
the blade and the angle's tight just
enough to Parry like so you'll try and
drive the blading still maintaining
contact on that all this wide around
movement is complete nonsense
okay knocking the blade down and
striking back up now you could argue
that this is almost a nodding in effect
the idea of beating someone's blade down
and then hitting back up with the false
Edge
here you see where the sword is sweeping
wide and one person is standing with
their point right in front of the other
you don't Parry then come back here you
stand here and you stab them immediately
because the blade has moved out of
presence
well that was good yep if someone has
got their back to you and you have a
spear do stab them in the back of the
leg that again redeeming feature that's
that's given another point
so I quite like the fight scene between
Brienne of Tarth and Aria I think that's
quite good it's cohesive it has that
real Focus to it so the movement is
constant neither of them is really
sacrificing there's no great pauses
there's always I want to be back in the
fight I want to be back in it
I do like in general the Hound fights
because they are just like men that's
good and I think
having that idea that a blade is
intrinsically there to either stab
someone or hit them with it and remove
all the sort of like fussy detail is a
very good thing to have in a series
first the twirling is Dreadful but the
the blades are all over the place
there's no safety in them and now we're
being focused on a single opponent we
could use the sword in a much more
efficient way
even if I were to twelve the swords
towards you you'd always want one blade
in presence always one blade doing
something never having the swords over
here
at that point I think the idea of
restraining to weapon hands becomes more
important than actually taking the
weapons out of the hand so at that point
I would suggest that potentially you're
looking at a way of either throwing the
opponent as far from you as possible
throwing them down the really big hole
on the other side of you might be a good
thing
up two
yep she's dead now
yeah you're really looking at just
absolute theater here and that's that's
fine it is what it is uh but it's it's
terrible terrible sword fighting this
idea of driving people apart to fight so
you don't want to be standing still you
don't want big people to be managing the
space while your space is getting more
and more cramped
one of the things that uh is
misunderstood quite often is that impact
molded blades quite often these were
given mirror polishes and I believe
unless this is anecdotal
um that there's reference to people
blowing on the blades so that the the
breath actually brings out the pattern
world for a moment so you can see it so
yeah blades historically are incredibly
highly Polished in various different
places certainly in Japanese stores
that's the thing certain European sort
of thing
interesting tactical decisions here so
you have a point where somebody has
control of the blade and if you think
like a parrying dagger you have have
really options to take the blade of the
opponent on your dagger or to take them
on your sword and to attack them with
the other but in order to do so you'd
want to maintain that contact so to do
an action like this with the opponent's
blade still directly in the middle
doesn't make any sense really so you had
a point of control or a point of control
both of those have been sacrificed
it's amazing that one of these people
didn't die in the process of this they
should have either been disembowelling
or a stab or whichever or the other
person should have plowed straight
through the middle in the space for from
the point of viewpoint of a good
cohesive fight scene that involves
realistic technique I'm going to give
that two
[Music]
okay the first miracle of this fight is
that they don't manage to kill each
other
um there there are forms which consist
about fighting around somebody usually
the other person is disabled so that
they're kind of in a position where you
don't have to worry about them they'll
be prone or something like this or
perhaps you'll be bodyguarding someone
so it's a way of moving around each
other I would not really like to have my
back to someone who was swinging
something sharp or Bernie
so much of this is almost a method to
show how he feels so you have an
expression of emotion going on in the
fight scenes rather than necessarily
being this very very tight cohesive
fight his anger is always explicit
everything is these white powerful
slashes that aren't necessarily good for
defense
it's so heavily stylized I think in
things like the
um Revenge of the Sith you have these
very very Dynamic fight scenes between
Obi-Wan and Anakin and those I think are
much more expressive at combat even if
the distance is a little bit funny even
if they're standing toe to turn waving
the swords around there's a lot more
aggression and interaction in that as
such I think I'd give it a 5 out of 10
as in it has aspects that I really enjoy
if I was going for my enjoyment of the
fight scene it would be innate
I really really love the Yoda fight
scenes I I always have um again it's
that point where you separate any desire
for reality it doesn't have to be real
you know if it's got dragons if it's got
the false it doesn't matter it has to be
something expressive of all the things
you want in there
yes absolutely if you can cut flesh you
can cut fabric it's again it depends on
on different things like how sharp the
sword is but they are made to cut things
the horses were very realistic let's
give it a one
hi I'm Toby capwell I'm curator of arms
and armor at the wireless collection in
central London since I was a kid I've
been riding horses and fighting in armor
I've taken part in competitions armored
combat all over the world
today we're going to be looking at the
treatment of medieval arms and armor in
cinema
oh stop stop did you see that
he just got shot in the armor and it
knocked him but it didn't stop him and
you know in a complete armor a medieval
Knight can suffer horrendous physical
punishment that would kill an unarmored
person like that but you can take the
hits and in armored combat there are
times when you decide to let your
opponent hit you because you know you
can take it and you're going to do
something else you're not going to waste
time defending what doesn't need to be
defended and the armor in this clip
takes on again narrative significance
it's storytelling he can take a shot
right in the chest that's a pretty big
character Point wouldn't you think he's
not clunking around all cumbersome he
moves like a real Knight I've been
jousting and fighting in armor for 30
years you know I built a lot of
different kinds of armor working with
different Craftsmen all over the world
real armor of the late Middle Ages the
Renaissance is like a steel skin
it's not bulky
it's your shape the armor should fit you
like a skin it should follow your
musculature it doesn't have to be a lot
of space under there it's fitted it
moves with you the plates are hardened
and tempered medium carbon steel so they
don't have to be thick and chunky they
need to Glide over each other and move
like you move
out of here without killing you he
hardly ever takes his helmet off and yet
you know everything about his expression
his feelings his character historically
a knight has a very close personal
relationship with his armorer that armor
is responsible for his safety
but he's also the guy who's going to
mold your character that's never really
been explored you know until this
I said where are they
it's got a couple of possible sources of
inspiration on the one hand it looks a
lot like an ancient Greek
hopalite's helmet the ancient Greek
heavy infantry of like 500 BC of
thereabouts these these very distinct
spectacled helmets with these like eye
cutouts the nasal for the nose and then
the cheeks brought in in the Bronze Age
they're trying again to get as much
protection for the face and the head as
they possibly can so that's where that
really closely set kind of spectacled
profile comes from that was then
imitated in the Renaissance you know in
the 15th century in Italy and very
rapidly everywhere else people were
became fascinated with the classical
world again and they started looking
back to the ancient Greek and Roman
precedent
and this style of helmet became
fashionable again in Italy and Venice in
the Venetian Empire specifically in the
15th century most used by infantry
shooting crossbows and and firearms and
more lightly armored troops and in the
ancient Greek period they they were the
heavy infantry but
um they still had Shields to hide behind
and they're actively protecting their
faces as well as
as well as relying on their armors I'd
give this a 10. absolutely
Vikings is a fantasy you should really
treat it as a fantasy there's a lot of
things to like about this show
and that makes it almost the more tragic
for me because those Anglo-Saxons are
all wearing late 16th century helmets
the bergenettes with the high comb and
the peak they are
800 years wrong
the leather biker gear
There is almost no historical evidence
for leather clothing almost across the
board people in the past did not make
clothes out of leather it's a distinctly
modern thing
it acts is fine I don't have a problem
with the ax I do have a problem with
none of the main characters wearing
helmets you can't go anywhere near a
battle like this without a helmet so I
mean someone like Ragnar lothbroker
someone of that stature would have
amazing male coat he'd have jewelry he'd
have big thick gold stuff on him he'd
have a gilded sword he does not have to
look like a pile of leather crap
I'm gonna give it a three
could not be undone
that is metal
nothing else looks like metal but metal
in close-up all that decoration is
etched into the steel with acid
this is film armor As Good As It Gets
now there are lots of great spraying
techniques and you can spray plastic to
look reflective and increasingly it
looks more and more like metal but it
doesn't behave like metal their armor is
a little you can see it's a little bit
too flexi there's something about metal
that it has a weight it has a rigidity
that rubber and plastic and polyurethane
don't have
he walks into the in into the battle and
you know everything you need to know
about this guy and it's all coming out
through his gear they've taken real 15th
century armor Styles mostly German
and then turned it up to 11. Sauron is
wielding a mace
and mesa's are real it's a hafted weapon
with a wooden or a steel haft with a
flanged or bladed head on one end so all
the weight of the weapon is balanced to
the end and it's a concussion weapon and
you're trying rather than to cut or
pierce your opponent you're trying to
smash through their defenses that is way
bigger in proportion to him than any
real maces were a real German Gothic
High medieval maces of the 15th century
are they're usually pretty short they're
like just a little bit you know more
than a foot or a bit more long the heads
are quite small
but they got these really sharp blades
on them and you're focusing your energy
on a really small area a weapon doesn't
need to be massive to have the effect
that it needs to have but massive always
reads well on screen especially when
you've got a dark lord of Mordor and and
how successfully does it use armor and
weapons to bring its characters and its
themes across I gotta give this 10 as
well
poor old r-pats looks like a pile of
garbage I'm afraid this is a mishmash
there are a couple of elements the
shoulders and the body armor that are
vaguely 15th century but they're about a
generation too late for Agincourt his
helmet is just ridiculous I mean that
has a vaguely 16th century profile to it
but it fits badly it's too big it's
clunky
oh come on man what is this
well this is obviously supposed to be
the Battle of Agincourt in 1415.
at the real Battle of Agincourt it was
very muddy the French had ten thousand
fully armed Knights that was the
entirety of their army they had archers
but they didn't use them the pada Calais
mud is like this thick gluey clay stuff
very difficult to move through
and it would be difficult regardless of
what you're wearing armor often gets
blamed for the French defeated Agincourt
as if the French were wearing heavy
armor that the English didn't were too
clever to wear or something the fact is
the English including Henry V here
were wearing full plate armor of the
time the English had 1500 fully armed
Knights whose job it was to protect
those famous archers
foreign
they go about it sort of the right way
in that this night is someone who's been
trained to fight and kill people since
he was a child and he's very very good
at it the only way you've got any chance
of this if you're an Archer an English
foot soldier or whatever is to get six
or seven or eight of your friends and
Pile in all at the same time don't take
turns he will kill all of you you gotta
all go together and four or five of you
got to hold him down and then one or two
of you have to stab him in the eyes and
in the gaps in the armor you don't stab
through the armor when uh King Richard
III was killed at the Battle of Bosworth
they immobilized him they held him down
someone took his helmet off they
probably cut the chin strap and took the
helmet off and then they can do as they
like they cut off the back of his skull
they stabbed him right through the brain
they did whatever they wanted I'll give
it a one because they've got mud and
archers working together but I can't
give it any more than a one it's it's a
it's a massive lost opportunity
[Applause]
it's a legal procedure
where they're determining the ownership
of territory with a trial by combat
they're attacking each other on the
wrong side if you can see they're
passing right to right which is wrong
they shouldn't be doing that because
your your rain hand is in your left hand
so it can't wield a weapon your rain
hand is in your left so your left side
is more exposed so that's where your
Shield goes your Lance is in your right
hand nobody's allowed to be left-handed
in the Middle Ages in traditional
nightly mounted combat like this you
always pass left side to left side
unhorsing someone is very difficult
and it only happens when certain key
factors all come together the timing's
got to be right the impact the placement
of the lands on the body's got to be
right where he is in his stride of the
horse when he gets hit all those lots of
things that kind of contribute to the
likelihood of being unhorsed but as a
general rule it's very very difficult
to separate a good Horseman from his
horse
if this was a later period in in like
the 15th century full play when you have
full plate armor you can be run over by
a horse in full plate armor and you'll
be just fine I've seen it happen this is
kind of a weird choice in this film
because el-sid Rodrigo de vivar is a
real person but he lived in the 11th
century in the the late 1000s
it's largely looking like the early to
mid 14th century
uh oh
the 16th century two-ended swords are
coming out now
we assume for some reason that a bigger
sword hits harder than a little sword
that you know these are not Firearms
this is not a higher caliber sword you
know they didn't have two-handed swords
in in l-sid's lifetime what you're
seeing Charlton wearing here is what's
traditionally referred to as string male
it's a knitted garment knitted with big
knitting needles
so you've got big Loops in the in the
weave of the knitting and then they iron
it flat spray it silver and it looks
like mail or they think it does it
doesn't really look that much like mail
but it's it's been the male substitute
for years and years and years and it's
fine you know for the background and I'd
still pass it for the background but you
can't have it in the foreground
5 out of 10.
and a diving suit is is very much like
armor in the sense that it protects you
from a hostile environment of a
different kind it's a complete fantasy
because he's not got an Air Supply
diving suits are a real historical thing
there are designs going back to the 14th
and 15th centuries in the late Middle
Ages
of designs for diving suits the skills
of the armorer would be recruited
for doing something like this they work
purely on a basic system of of water
displacement the suit is not watertight
the water can get in you pump air into
the helmet and it displaces the water
below your face
but the water as the pump is going up
and down the water goes up like this and
it sometimes covers your face and
sometimes goes down and you hope they
pump hard enough to keep you from
drowning it's dicey but it's possible I
give it a seven it's very very
interesting
thank you
hey what's he doing stop that
oh can't do that that's not how you take
a sword apart I'm sorry
this whole idea of melting a sword blade
down and then recasting it in a mold
which is what they're doing
you can't do that if you reduce the the
iron or the steel to its liquid state
you lose all of the properties that you
want if you melt and cast iron in a mold
it's cast iron and it becomes really
brittle and you can't temper it and you
can't heat treat it you know when you
have a lump of iron ore as it comes out
of the ground yes they heat the iron ore
to to separate the iron from all of the
silicates and the the rest of the stuff
that it's mixed up with you never fully
melt it you don't bring it up to the
full melting point you heat it up until
the chemical reaction occurs in the ore
which separates the iron from all of the
other junk and it sort of gloops down
into the bottom of the bloomery
weaponsmiths are very very careful never
to fully melt anything you cannot melt
armor down and make new armor I don't
care if it looks good on screen it's
dumb I like some of the things that that
Game of Thrones does with armor but
that's a fail that's a zero
I love the sort of evil Statue of
Liberty sort of you know aesthetic here
I I think the the star of that scene is
the flail real flails are derived from
farm implements they articulated staffs
that are used for threshing wheat and if
you have a feudal peasant Army and they
need to take whatever hurty things are
to hand a flail you know agricultural
implements are good it's a staff with
just an eye bolt articulation and then
another piece of wood when such an idea
is weaponized more extensively
they add a short length of chain between
the staff and the head flails almost
exclusively are a lower class common
Soldier infantry weapon the knights
didn't use them because they're kind of
scary and they have an inherent
mechanical Intrigue they've become much
more famous and much more popular to the
kind of
popular conception of the medieval night
than than they really deserve to be but
it's great here I mean again it totally
works here no flail was ever that big no
flail ever had a chain that long but in
this context it works great I can't
think of another weapon
that would have the kind of
Visual and Story character driven impact
that this has in this scene it's got to
be a 10 out of 10.
he'd be dead
be very dead one man can't attack a
shield wall like that
nobody ever used rectangular Shields I
mean that's ridiculous it's stupid and
real early medieval Shields which were
all circular as far as we can tell if
air can get through then a lot of other
things can get through most real Shields
of this period are made out of uh of
boards placed you know edge to edge
sort of like this but they're placed
properly edge to edge and they're glued
and they're sealed and you know there's
there's arguments good arguments be made
for them then being edged with uh
Rawhide or sometimes covered with hide
or textile and glue you should not be
able to see that much air through your
Shield
[Applause]
he's been stabbed right through the
chest between those plates they're
showing you
how their own
made-up silly armor doesn't work you
know now maybe if he gets hit full in
the chest with a spear that's wielded by
someone who knows how to use it his
padded textile and male armor uh which
is what he should be wearing or even
maybe a scale arm or maybe it wouldn't
stand up either no I can't I'm sorry I I
can't find anything to hold on to that's
a zero
[Music]
Badlands technique I'll give them a pass
on that because they wouldn't have known
what good Lance technique is
it's a very common thing in jousting
sequences in movies that they lower
their lands
to a horizontal and then they kick on
and Gallop along and they're Galloping
along with their Lance on the level you
don't do that you're sitting on a horse
you've got 12 feet of pine Lance and the
horse is going up and down like this and
you've got it here it's inevitable that
it's going to start to do this and
pretty and it's got a steelhead on the
end there's weight right out on the end
of that and pretty soon this thing is
going up and down and you couldn't hit a
you know a barn door with the thing
you've got no chance of controlling
where that spear goes and you get the
horse going and then you don't have to
worry about your opponent until the last
second or so of the interaction
and then it comes down boom
it takes practice if you're too late you
miss if you're too early you get tangled
up and look like an idiot but if you get
it right you're always you're always on
a Lance came down it got tangled up with
my Lance and a jousts and it came down
and the steel spearhead which has three
prongs like this two of the prongs went
past my hand and the third one bypassed
the defenses of my armor The Gauntlet it
went just under the plate through the
leather glove and into me I finished the
competition before I even realized I
needed to go get sewn up
yields her I have the advantage now
again this is all metal armor it's all
aluminum
aluminum sprayed black or aluminum
polished but look how good it looks they
worked hard to do what they were doing
and they knew what they were doing and I
think it deserves a seven
[Music]
traditional ranged weapons like the
Longbow and the crossbow
um you know the projectile
you know isn't moving that fast but it's
still moving way fast enough
you you can't you can't block arrows
remove the hood in The Mask
[Laughter]
it's an interesting outfit he's got on
you know who's he come as he's got a
vaguely 11th or early 12th century
helmet
but he's got full plate armor under
there like the 16th century or something
I'll give it a two because it's funny
and it's Nicholas Cage what business
there's an elf a man and a dwarf having
the Ridder Mark let's speak quickly yeah
this is a great entrance or a character
you know Tolkien imagined the rohiram as
Anglo-Saxons who fought like Knights on
Horseback because the Anglo-Saxon didn't
they rode horses but they got off to
fight they didn't fight on their horses
the design of the helmet is derived from
early medieval examples he really should
have his chin strap done up the helmet
is riding a bit too high on his head the
brow of the helmet the the vert the
horizontal Edge there should be right
down on his eyebrows to really protect
the front of the skull you want to bring
that down as far as it can go and it can
go right down onto your eyebrows so I'll
stick this on all right this is one of
my own made for me
okay now you see that brow is right down
on my eyes and it's sticking out beyond
my skull right so a weapon comes in
it can't get to me
the skull it might get there but that's
still safe
give me your name horse Master you know
things are often more highly decorated
even for practical fighting than modern
people often imagine they're going for
armor that looks kind of architectural
like the dwarves build you know caves
and they work with you know rock and
it's under mountains and stuff so
they're they're looking for a kind of
Blocky aesthetic it's starting to look a
bit too much like like polyurethane here
to me something about metal that it has
a weight it has a rigidity that rubber
and plastic and polyurethane don't have
I gotta dock them a couple of points
here for the fit and the chin strap but
it's still got to be like an eight out
of ten
doing I think his son was already a
knight at this point I don't know why he
feels the need to night him again
this is a this is a total mishmash of
pretty good and pretty not so good the
male that you're seeing in close up here
is real mail and you can actually even
see the rivets that are closing each of
the links it's not fitting him well
and it's not tailored to him it's
something that's been just hiked out of
a van and stuck on the actor a lot of uh
film mail is just like plastic links
butted together sprayed silver for a lot
of uses is fine but they don't have the
rivets real mail is you know Iron links
riveted closed I appreciate the fact
that he's got a lining under there he's
got padded textile under the mail which
you have to have otherwise it is going
to do precisely nothing for you a lot of
exposed throats there and they've stuck
random articulated shoulder plates over
the male shirt this is Robert the Bruce
in the early 14th century
they were starting to introduce more
hard armor they're a long way from Full
plate armor at this period there are
significant Way Away really from
articulated constructions like that that
look a bit like the tail of a lobster or
whatever it's a later thing
and the shoulders were less of a
priority in this period if you're going
to put plates on a guy in this period it
should be on the elbows and the knees
and here you can see his male is a
little off center his bagging around his
throat just as bad the key thing about a
male hood is that it has a piece called
a ventail which comes up and ties up to
the chin and it's sculpted to protect
the whole throat you know this is this
is armor that's doing nothing because I
can stab him straight through his
windpipe this film is is actively
engaging with real heraldry heraldry is
the system of colors and shapes put onto
Shields as a form of visual
identification
so when all these guys are in armor it's
hard to tell who's who heraldry was the
answer and it works very well they got
things wrong that they didn't have to
get wrong but they still did a fair
amount that's right
seven out of 10.
what nothing
I like this little scene because
it shows that getting shot with arrows
isn't immediately fatal and Gilda Ray
here Jones companion who is incidentally
a serial killer in real life he was a
quite pretty despicable child murderer
and but anyway he knows that he can take
a hit she's not wearing armor in this
scene he is shot for shot a long bow
arrow has very little chance of hurting
a man inside you need the kind of mass
volume that Henry V organized in his
armies to put so many arrows downrange
that somebody's gonna get hurt no matter
what
I asked for grandiose coronation and
this is what you get this
he wouldn't do that almost certainly
he'd wear his coronation robes and all
of his nights certainly wouldn't wear
armor to a coronation
certainly not Rusty banged up stuff like
that most of this is aluminum this armor
is made by Terry English who's one of
the most famous modern armors working in
cinema he's made armor for lots of
things he made Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Mr Freeze armor for the Batman movie
he's made Space Marines armor for the
aliens and he's done a fair amount of
historical stuff the king here is
putting on gold armor it's gold colored
and this is actually this is actually
good this doesn't look like gold armor
but fully gilded armor where you have
steel armor
and then it's copper plated
and then it's fire gilded where you mix
gold with Mercury and you apply this
Mercury gold mixture if you then heat
that mercury up and you boil it off it
leaves the gold chemically bonded to the
steel normally most people wouldn't be
able to afford that I mean really only
Kings can afford this and not all Kings
but the French Kings like this it was it
was a distinctive uh thing actually it
creates an image of a king as like the
sun manifested in human form like a
superhuman being but it would have been
nicer if they'd given Terry the budget
to Guild it properly
I'll give it a 4 out of 10. we've
already been through this before we both
know you haven't got it in a sword is
not a gun pointing a sword at someone
out of range with your arms fully
extended so you have nowhere to go with
it doesn't achieve anything except
making you look like you've never held a
sword in your life you point your weapon
out there like that he's going to take
it away from you
[Music]
there's often not enough color in
medieval depictions in cinema medieval
people loved color bright color and
richness it didn't populate their world
very much otherwise
okay so you've got your leader your king
leading a cavalry charge he they're in
wedge formation with the king at the
point of the wedge which is great this
is how it's done the guy on the point of
the wedge is steering the whole cavalry
charge he's like the guidance system on
a missile the wedge formation is one of
the most effective formations for a
heavy cavalry charge these guys chin
strap done up love that he's still got
his visor up which is good because at
this stage he's still far enough away
from the enemy where he's got other
things to worry about a cavalry charge
might start when you're Maybe
600 meters away from the enemy line
but you're not going to be full Pelt
straight off you need to start the
charge in good order he's got to look
around and make sure his formation is
maintaining its position they're keeping
their cohesion if he starts running too
fast then they then they have to catch
up and then they start getting too
spread out they've got to stay close
he's got to be watching that fine but
now the real test of this sequence and
the thing that Hollywood hates to do is
cover its famous actors faces but in a
real cavalry charge this guy once he's
got himself set up he needs to close
that visor
and let's see if they do it he could
close it right about now
would be good
ah he's closed it I give it a seven
if I could change one thing I would
change this he's wearing his courgette
on the outside of his breastplate
the gorgette is that neck plate
he should actually have plates covering
his throat the gorgette has neck plates
in here and it comes down and has this
larger chest plate that chest plate
should be underneath
the breastplate the breastplate has a
turned Edge to stop things sliding up
into your face but if anything does get
past it hits the gorget but in Game of
Thrones they habitually put them on the
outside and it's a it's a howler that I
just I can't abide
and fire arrows were a thing especially
in Naval Warfare when you've got key
pieces of equipment you want to set on
fire like sails and rigging and things
fire arrows as a rule get get way
overused in cinema these are a little
more interesting though there's
something more interesting going on you
see it's not just a lump of burning
material stuck on an arrow they've
actually got some kind of explosive
charge on these arrows that has a fuse
and this is actually much more
historically plausible there are early
incendiary manuals from the 15th and
16th centuries that give designs for
different kinds of gunpowder bombs and
other explosive devices to be put on
arrows and crossbow bolts
I love this right here that's armor
doing its job
you know an arrow when it hits you in
full armor it'll probably glance off
that's what Armor's designed to do but
if it hits you square and it gets enough
purchase it can it can start to bite
into the steel and if it hits you
somewhere on the arm or the shoulder
where the steel is thinner it might even
get through chances are most arrows are
not going to get through enough to do
meaningful damage the person inside but
they are going to get stuck and seeing a
knight fighting on the walls in a Siege
with arrows stuck in him is the best
thing I've seen all day 10 out of 10
absolutely just for that hi my name is
teclaudeva I'm a stunt woman and martial
arts world champion and I've been doing
nunchucks and martial arts in general
for about 18 years today we'll be
looking at nunchuck scenes in movies
it's very traditional nunchuck style
it's a lot of the passing under the hand
stuff which is super cool and like more
old school the longer chain ones might
be more practical the longer the chain
the further your reach is this is about
the length I think that they were in
that last clip because the ones I
compete with it's a shorter chain so you
can do more like flourishy things with
it
not only did he hold it normal grip
which is your thumb facing the chain
pretty much but whenever he switched his
his hands he had them backwards uh a few
times you don't see that often it's a
style I think it's like knife you know
you have like your regular standard grip
and then you have like ice pick where
it's upside down so I guess that'd be
like the ice pick version which is cool
this is the normal grip but it's neat to
see it this way because obviously it
works the same way but
it's just cool
you don't have to start under the armpit
I think that's another just traditional
move that usually like spin it catch it
under the armpit and then shoot it back
out again I think maybe that's more of a
sneaky way to do it as opposed to like
being loaded here right you're here and
then everyone's like oh there's no way
and there's like traditional weapons
especially come from like farm tools
this was just for like smacking grain
out of hay and like wheat and stuff and
then someone's like hmm this works on
grain I wonder what it'll do to
someone's face I can't write Bruce Lee
10.
all right maybe maybe nine because he
showed off for way too long
you can kind of see a little bit and
some of it where maybe the actress isn't
completely that well versed with the
nunchucks they're a little bit slower
she's kind of using more of her body and
like more of her arms and stuff instead
of just like moving the nunchuck very
skillfully but obviously she's quite
skilled there's a few cool moves though
the neck sliding under the legs and
hitting him it's pretty cool but it's
definitely not as realistic to think
that she wouldn't just be grabbed or
something if she's being a lot more like
calculating and like choreographed with
it
the last move where she like puts it on
her foot and kicks it I've seen actually
like done in forms I'd say like seven
but I still love it
oh double there we go he's just doing
the same combo over and over I love it
it's funny how often it's just like the
demonstration of the weapon especially
with nunchucks is like
the bit that that is so highlighted he
did a good job like obviously it was him
doing it and like the move where he like
crosses them isn't very easy to do
if I were to be in a fight with
nunchucks I think I would just try to
make the big swinging strikes the best
one's probably from top to bottom at the
angles you do side to side or like a
nice uppercut anything else ends up
being a lot more specific also I mean
growing knees those are always like
defaults for self-defense moves and a
nunchuck to the kneecap wouldn't be very
comfortable so that'd probably be a good
one too like what he did you know just
like wailing on him was probably
like a really you know good default I
want to say they're foam ones in that
scene too just by the weight that it
looked like they had when it bounced
back real nunchucks are made out of wood
they're illegal in California it's just
always such an interesting question that
like people ask that kind of confuses me
sometimes about like are they real if
you're training with a sword if it's
made out of metal it is but if it's not
sharp then I guess it's not real like
these are real they're just foam so it's
like a weird
you know like what the definition of a
real weapon is he just did the
demonstration which was really cool but
the actual fight bit was like three
moves and the nunchuck bounced back so
like a five
yes concealed carry nunchucks so cool
I've been known to just keep them in a
backpack or a purse because I forgot
that they're there so they are very like
concealable
I don't
I love that he used it
to take on a bunch of people surrounding
him because I feel like that's probably
the best use of it just because if you
spin around fast enough like people
aren't going to want to attack you I
think that is a really good use of a
flaily weapon like if you had a stick
someone might grab it like disarm them
or you know like it's it's an easier
thing to catch when it's like one stick
but when it's an unchecked like it's
terrifying it's scary for the person
wielding it much less someone in front
those swords are made really well
because they're like layered bits of
bamboo together I think it would have to
be a really like perfect storm for that
to actually happen seeing as how like
these aren't very sharp but it's Donnie
in so you know like
it's possible if they wanted to swarm
him they could have like beaten him but
I I think it's a really good way to
capture the like efficiency and the use
of the actual weapon so I don't know
nine a fellow Checker eh
yeah I mean rolling it over your hand is
all always harder it involves letting go
of one of them and just letting it roll
over your hand and get to the other one
it's hard to do with the longer chain
because you have to be able to get that
so I'd say like straight strikes are the
easiest and then something with a spin
and then something with a release as far
as difficulty tears so like that
difficulty scale
and those speed I think are pretty good
signs of like
expertise
you gotta love Ninja Turtles it's like
the Dueling Pianos thing keep practicing
see this is where nunchucks get a bad
rep they're like oh no one's actually
doing anything with them and then the
guy with the stick comes in and beats
everyone up but if they actually got
close enough where ducks would hit
someone maybe the guy with the bow staff
wouldn't have to be there they showed
some good expertise with the nunchucks
but there was Zero fight actual
interaction so I'll have to give it like
a two or three
but again for the demonstration bit
maybe like a six or seven
so pass around the back nice again with
this you see a lot of just straight
strikes not so much fancy stuff when
you're actually interacting with people
with which again like it's the diagonal
strikes the sideways ones upwards
hitting the guy out of the air was
probably the least practical thing I
still liked Donnie Yen's version better
with like everyone attacking at once
because again this was a little more
choreographed where like all the bad
guys come in at their designated time
which is plausible you know of course
but I think if you're a mob trying to
end up hurting someone you just like go
like one two three let's go
oh
finishes them off with a kick he used a
lot more you know like martial arts
kicks and and other other movement as
opposed to just swinging the nunchuck
around because obviously someone who can
do nunchucks should have some background
in martial arts it made it feel more
realistic because of that as well the
strikes were awesome but then there were
a few of the more intricate things like
it when he like wrapped the guy's arm
which I feel like
took a little longer than it probably
practically would like you if someone's
punching you don't really have all that
time for that to happen it's plausible
of course like while it still fell very
specifically choreographed it was a lot
more believable than the Kick-Ass one
where there were just like such so many
specialty moves
but really sucked to get cracked like
across the jaw or like the eyes
obviously a sharp weapon is more
practical in a real fight if you're
actually wanting to like hurt people
that bad but I do think you know what
you're doing they end up being like a
stick I used to think that they're not
as effective or as good because I
thought they'd like bounce back but
again if you don't hit with anything but
the last bit it just whips by a little
bit and then you have a lot of power in
that last bit maybe not the easiest
thing to use in a real fight but I do
think they could probably be pretty
devastating if you know how to use them
right maybe like a seven
that would suck I feel like the physics
of that doesn't quite work but it's a
cool move you know
I liked the Bruce Lee character dodging
he's very skilled to dodge that close to
the nunchucks but I liked him going
stepping offline and like punching the
guy and taking the nunchucks which is
what you want to do with disarming a
weapon of any sort right like you want
to kind of get in past it and get past
the like that end where that's the most
power is
there was one bit where he like hits the
pipe and then hits the guy's hand which
is really like a cool take on it because
like hitting fingers would suck whereas
you're not gonna disarm the pipe out of
someone's hand important muscles for
using nunchucks uh one of the main ones
is actually your wrist for the more
intricate movements and then obviously
your arm and your back and power comes
from your hips range of motion is very
important arguably more important than
muscle mass this one's tough because I
liked this one showed like a variety of
styles but like if we have to rate it on
practicality like seven or something
Jackson
these people need to start holding on to
their weapons a little better yeah it's
funny to keep seeing that theme of just
people taking nunchucks from other
people in all of these I've never
noticed that until you have them back to
back you're like what is going on
I don't know if I would block an ax with
it just because I'm not sure how sharp
the ax is and how heavy and like it's
kind of a small chain so it it's not
unlikely that it might snap it there's
also other blocks like this ends up
actually being a block as well because
you're here you're blocking all that and
then you can also kind of block if you
just hold them their stick on your arms
so that's a good block as well again
like I don't think they're the most
secure things to block with but that's
not a horrible move especially if you're
stepping off to the side just to like
ensure you're gonna not be hit if
something does happen probably Perry
instead of just block straight on I
don't think it showed off like the
practicality of nunchucks all that well
you'd have to be very skilled and very
specific with your movement to be able
to pull that off at all and I wouldn't
recommend it so maybe like a five but it
was a cool little scene
oh there's that move again
I mean he obviously knows what he's
doing based on our criteria from earlier
like the intricacy switching hands and
the speed at which he's moving them and
the spins and everything so that's
really cool to see I
grip it
like uh maybe a thumb width away from
the chain and the top because that's
where you have the most control over the
other stick as well I guess for like
distance and like just the straight
strikes you might grip it a little lower
and then also depending on the intricacy
of your movement sometimes for some
moves you want to grip it a little bit
lower so that you can get it around your
hand for that or you want to grip it a
little higher if you're doing like a
finger spin or something but generally
speaking you want to be close to the
chain on top and then all you have to
worry about is where the chain is
flinging the rest of it so it's a lot
more controlled
I don't do the like eyes fluttering
thing it is kind of indicative of not
knowing the distance and like location
of the nunchucks or any weapon really
like I think people do that with both
staff and sword and stuff as well even
if it's just foam like if I throw it and
lose track of it then I do that
obviously but I I do know where they're
going most of the time but you
definitely hit yourself quite a bit
especially at first when you're still
learning and if you're not being smooth
a lot of times it's like Funny Bone
which is fantastic back of the head
which I'm not even sure how that gets
there but that's a good one also makes a
really good sound they're definitely
special
but I've never like
knocked myself out with them or like
anything horrible so practicality wise I
mean like probably like the four or five
again just because like
some of the strikes didn't look like
they hit exactly
oh this is the
quintessential scene I can't rag on this
canceled immediately I like how I feel
like it is realistic how few times they
hit each other with them and how much
more it is kind of like a distraction
like that first move he did he does like
a briefly just like a distraction move
and then kicks him in the uh like the
ankle to throw them off so like that
stuff's more practical I think it felt
maybe not like gritty realistic but it
did feel realistic within like if you're
sparring with someone you're gonna show
off your moves and everything and like
kind of like test the waters and the
distance which they were doing a lot
during like demonstration periods and
just kind of showing off a very simple
straight across strikes which would work
but yeah I think that's one of the best
ones we've seen for sure I'd say that's
the 10.
oh
so the spear kind of beat the nunchucks
in that I think even though she won
definitely less intricate movement it
was kind of nice that there wasn't a
demonstration of skill in this one it
was just like it went right to the fight
maybe the nunchucks weren't the right
choice for that girl to use in that
fight against the spear it wasn't bad I
just I think the other ones obviously
were much stronger
showing the benefit of nunchucks and
like the practicality of it and the
impact of them because even in this like
she hit the girl across the face but
like there wasn't a lot of impact on how
that would actually feel and I think the
distance again looked a little off
because they were so close so a lot of
her strikes ended up being a little
weaker looking the distance felt a
little off and the filming didn't quite
showcase the nunchucks as well as some
of the other Clips would have so maybe
like a four or three hi I'm Matt Easton
of scholar gladiatori and I teach people
how to use things like Spears and swords
and daggers and I also deal in antique
weapons I've been teaching people how to
use weapons for 20 years so today we're
going to be looking at some pole arm
combat scenes from movies
foreign
okay so stabbing the foot there that was
really nice and I think a lot of people
might think that's silly but funnily
enough there's an anonymous treaties
from the early 16th century that's
repeatedly talks about stabbing the
opponent in the foot and stabbing them
in the crotch uh so so absolutely it was
done
this kind of distraction tactic is in
medieval treatises though I love it
okay whoa whoa there's there's lights
flipping this spinning this thing around
so this is a thrusting weapon but she is
twirling it around like a snooker queue
in a bar fight that's not going to have
much effect on people it's not a good
striking weapon thrust with it it's a
spear
taking turns so this is this is a
favorite way for multiple people to
attack a hero in a movie or a big
villain is to take turns at attacking
them just attack them at the same time
don't go one two three four so if they
are trying to surround him they should
still have their spare points forward
predominantly and form essentially a
ring of points around him perhaps the
only excuse you could give them is
they're trying to capture him rather
than trying to kill him one of the
things that really bugs me about spear
use in Black Panther is that the spears
are used more like quarter staffs now
not to say you can't use a spear like a
quarter stuff you can strike with a
spear it's just not the most efficient
and effective way of using a spear if
you've got a sharp Point use the sharp
points so I've got to be honest I am
going to give it a 3 out of 10.
so tridents absolutely were used in
combat most famously by Roman gladiators
of course that's the most famous example
but tridents did continue existing into
the medieval period the fact that you've
got multiple projections at the head the
fact that they are heavier this is a
heavier weapon designed for fighting
against armor in that sense that makes
them more like this polax here he seems
to have a secondary cross guard a little
bit lower down which is quite
interesting because there's a parallel
with European pole axes there as well
which has a hand guard here that's not
only to protect the hand but it's also
to give more Force to the push so if
you're fighting an armor and you plant
the cross as it's called in their armpit
and you want to push them it gives you
something harder to push against
so that one of the first things to note
is how twirly this light is I'm not a
huge fan of such turning I mean they
turn their backs on each other so much
so there's a really nice technique there
where he basically turns the back end of
his weapon around his opponent's neck in
order to throw him it's sort of an
impression of some of the techniques
that we do see in historical treatises
and in armor this is a very good way of
overcoming someone if they can get up
but it's not that easy and it's not very
quick that gives you the opportunity to
um to attack them while they're on the
ground and disadvantaged and you can
look for the gaps in the armor like
their armpits
there's a really nice technique there um
where the bad guy at one end of his
weapon is is locked up and so he swings
the other end of the weapon round to
strike with the back end and again
that's completely typical of polax
combat if one end gets occupied or dealt
with then that being pushed aside you
immediately come around with the other
end or the middle I would give this
about a five
so Troy is really really interesting
because it's one of those rare occasions
in uh movie fights where we see them
actually attempting to use Spear and
shields together you know the spear and
shield was absolutely the this standard
dueling weapon for Heroes to fight with
in the ancient world and you only have
to look at ancient Greek vases to see
the two Heroes standing in front of each
other with the spear raised and the
shield in front of them
Achilles lances his spear out at maximum
length with a Thrust and that is
predominantly how Spears are supposed to
be used you grip it as near to the back
of the shaft as you possibly can it's
actually remarkably difficult to find an
opening to stab with a spear if the
opponent has a large Shield as here
that's why people used them
pretty nice detail there we see Achilles
switching
um the the spear around so he's using
both ends of it and in fact we know in
the ancient Greek World Spears often
have two ends on them throughout history
a lot of types of Spears have two ends
on them so you can stab with the main
principle end but you can also stab with
the the foot end or the heel it's not
usually so sharp or so big because it
has to stand on the ground at all the
time but nevertheless if you're being
stabbed with it it's fairly unpleasant
so there was one little Minor Detail
there that kind of bugs me a hectare
basically kind of slashes with his Spear
and now with a typical spearhead like
this it's not going to have a lot of
cutting potential so you know I suppose
it's fair that it in a pinch you might
do this to make someone back off
especially if it's kind of face level so
it's going to make a person Flinch or
move away but even if it had connected
it wouldn't have done an awful lot of
damage it would have been like being hit
with a stick basically
resting the the spear on his kind of
back and thrusting over the top of his
shield this is incredibly short range
and I think of dubious use
breaking a spear shaft with a shield
would that work probably not look at
movies where things like this spear are
chopped through with a sword we've done
experiments we've tried to do it you can
cut through a spear shaft but it takes
several blows with a sharp sword but
it's not a lightsaber breaking through
one with a shield even less likely so
really spear shafts are designed to be
relatively durable relatively light but
not super light but pretty strong if
they're not strong then they're not
going to work as effective weapons
we see uh Achilles's spear get broken by
being stamped on now this is slightly
more plausible I don't think it'd be as
easy as it's shown here however it's
more plausible than breaking it with a
shield an eight out of 10.
[Music]
this is a very special Javelin but this
is an Olympic style Javelin it's not
really a weapon if it's the same as a
typical one it's an aluminum tube with a
kind of slightly pointy end so this is
not something that's designed to you
know penetrate thick clothing or go
through armor or anything else and I
have to say they're not terribly strong
either I mean if you stepped on one you
could quite easily bend it
[Music]
she's using it like a giant lightsaber
as if it's it's magically cutting
through people but I don't understand
how or why
[Music]
finally a stab or a double stab so
finally she thrusts with it I have no
issue with that of she actually used a
spear like a spear eventually but you
know what's all the swinging it around
it what's it it's not going to cut
anything I'm going to give this uh a one
out of ten
it really really bugs me how he uses
this spear it is the most stupid way
that he could have used this spear
basically he could have won this fight
in the first few seconds if he just used
it like a spear instead he uses it like
I I don't know like a broom handle he
thrusts with the wrong foot backward
giving himself the minimum reach he's
got enough space especially in the
corridor to occupy that space with the
point of the spear and keep the opponent
in front of him so the main advantage of
any pole arm but particularly of Spears
is reach but with reach also comes
leverage the two things go hand in hand
a small movement at the back end needs a
large movement at the top end so quite
simply if you're trying to get around an
opponent's Shield you can go from high
to low you could go above the shield and
below the shield in the blink of an eye
which takes longer to do with a sword
the usual balance is a spear person can
beat two swords people if there's no
armor and no Shields involved a spear is
a game changer yeah
the spares can can block with with any
part of the shaft you can block with the
tail end sometimes the middle of the
shaft can be used the problem with using
the middle is it means any defense is
closer to your body but most
predominantly Spears are used with the
pointy end projecting forwards and most
of the defense will be done with the
front end the way he used this spear is
infuriating and at one point he's even
got the spearhead pointing backwards
away from the opponent while holding the
blunt end outwards I mean he doesn't
even have two spiky ends
it's an entirely metal spear which is
unusual generally you wouldn't want to
make a spear entirely out of metal
because although it would be stronger it
would be so heavy that it would give up
the advantages that the spear has if you
make it heavy it also makes it far
easier for the opponent to grab although
they have a lot of advantages of reach
and leverage they are way way easier to
grab the opponent to grab hold of than
something like a sword a sword is mostly
blade so it's harder to grab this
particular fight will get a really low
score of two out of ten yeah I love this
episode but this fight just sucked
oh
foreign
too much swinging of the spear not
enough thrusting frosting doesn't look
as impressive on screen it's also
slightly more dangerous for the actors
as well despite the fact that in the
modern world we probably think of axes
or swords associated with Vikings in any
army in the so-called Dark Ages in the
early medieval period the spear and
shield was the primary weapon of battle
they fought in Shield walls with a spear
yet richer people might have a sword and
other people might have an ax but those
are weapons that are only really useful
once you're you've closed Beyond spear
range
thank you one of the great things about
Spears is they are one of the best hand
weapons that you can have in your hand
and they're also a really good missile
weapon at any moment they can get thrown
and psychologically that makes a huge
difference within the fight even if the
opponent doesn't throw the spear the
knowledge that they could throw it at
any moment as Javelin really changes how
you fight it makes sure you keep your
Shield up it makes you very wary I've
once been in a fight in a tournament in
fact where the opponent had a spear and
shield I had sword and shield so I'm up
there preparing to protect my my head
and my and my torso against the spear
throw and I get a spear right in the leg
and if that had been a real Spear and
gone through my leg then I wouldn't have
been fighting anymore Throne Spears are
incredibly powerful they will stick
deeply into a shield if they hit you in
the body
um you're in big big trouble I mean
they'll go through a person's torso and
they'll also penetrate certain types of
armor I would give this six out of 10.
so what we see here is the famous Pike
Phalanx uh these are macedonians but
Pike phalanxes were used all over the
ancient world they were used by the
Romans initially as very good against
Cavalry it makes it very difficult for
Cavalry to operate on the battlefield
these are very very long Spears you're
far more limited than how you can use
them you don't generally turn them
around and use the back end although
these Pikes do have a counterbalance on
the back end with a spike on it now
that's partially so if the pike gets
broken you can turn it around and use
the other end still as a weapon also it
provides a counterbalance so you can
hold more of the pike out in front hop
lights were quite characteristic for
using the pike two-handed they needed to
use it two-handed because it was so big
and relatively heavy but they also use
Shields and so what they did is they
strapped the shield in such a way that
they can hide behind the shield to some
degree obviously protection against
arrows but also protection against enemy
Pikes this has been represented very
very well very accurately
so against arrows it's difficult because
you you know you're holding a great long
Pike with two hands and you kind of got
the shield suspended it's not that easy
to at that point put your Shield up
because you're not really holding the
shield in the typical way and also the
shield doesn't cover your whole body the
problem with arrows is they'll they'll
find it doesn't matter how good the
armor is or what Shields you're carrying
they will find gaps so absolutely
peppering a Phalanx with arrows it is
good advice
look like the pike is traveling very
very quickly and piercing bodies and the
one thing you have to say about Pikes is
they don't move quickly because they
only move as quickly as the pipe block
moves you can stab a bit with the pike
but it doesn't go through an awful lot
of motion eight out of ten
so it's a massive massive glaze yeah
glaive is an English word for for a
weapon that's essentially like a a
falcon or Broad Sword on the end of a
stick so it has the reach of a pole arm
but it has the cutting and thrusting
abilities and type of a sword and it
would be a form of Dal a Dao is a
single-edged weapon so it's something
that's very effective at cutting that's
a very very big glaive head so this is
this is a heavy pole arm
foreign
like The Cutting mechanics that he's
doing they're pretty pretty good but why
have they got to grappling distance he
shouldn't have allowed The Swordsman to
get that close if you get to grappling
distance The Swordsman has the advantage
just spinning around the neck it's not
something you'd really want to do in a
real fight at all unless you wanted to
lose
I wouldn't say
really holding it in the most logical
logical because he's given up all of his
reach Advantage by holding it across his
body the opponent's got a sword he's got
a weapon that's twice its length so he
should be using the reach Advantage I
mean it's beautifully choreographed but
a lot of it is totally unrealistic to
how you'd actually use those weapons and
that goes for the swords or the pole
arms three out of ten
so the the bad guy has what we would
call we'd probably call it a form of
halberd so a halberd is essentially an
ax Blade with a with a rear Spike and
usually they have a top Spike but if the
ax blade is shaped to have a top Spike
already then you don't need an
additional top Spike
foreign
it looks comedic but actually can you
think if you're occupying a space how
intimidating that would be this is a
weapon which weighs probably if it was a
real one and if it was steel probably
about six pounds if someone's got a six
pound weapon of which about five pounds
of that is the end and they're whirling
it around that's really really
intimidating one hit from that and
you're going down
absolutely the right thing against the
pole arm wielders I really really liked
it as a fight an eight out of ten hi I'm
Shane Adams the owner of the Knights of
Valor full contact jousting company I've
been jousting for well over 25 years
since I have 20 International jousting
championships under my belt today we're
going to be looking at horseback fights
and movies
they hit but it was just a a glancing
blow there is no penalty for missing
your opponent but you're going to be uh
you know behind in points if you hit the
target whether it be a a smooth plate or
whether it be a Target Shield you get a
certain amount of points and ultimately
if you unhorse your opponent in the full
contact style that's the maximum amount
of points there there's you know
probably well over 19 20 25 different
styles of jousting
foreign
yeah see that Ridge around that Shield
bad news you don't want a lip around the
shield you don't want any spot where
that Lance is going to connect and lock
into the lip you want to be able to
deflect the Lance away from your body so
it's a completely wrong Shield
the jousting that was there
for a theatrical style joust if there
were true Knights they wouldn't be
holding their Shields like that they're
leaving themselves completely exposed
from the top of the shield to your
throat had that scene where the horse
actually does fall into the joust list
usually it would be the opposite way so
the person would be getting hit coming
off to the right side based on the fact
that we do real full contact jousting we
always drop the reins so that way there
if you get off balance you're not going
to be pulling your horse to the extent
that you're going to be pulling your
horse down onto the ground with you I'm
265 pounds add my armor I'm 415 pounds
riding a 2 000 pound horse charging at
20 25 miles an hour against the same
opposing force it it's a car wreck so
when we hit there is a lot of force
being generated
both guys were not wearing proper
equipment as far as Gorges to protect
their necks because the Lance can hit
and come up and straight into your
throat you could tell right away looking
at the tips of the lances the hounds
Lance didn't have a Cornell on it didn't
have like a tip on the end it was a
sheer Point nights back in the olden
days the nobility were the ones jousting
they didn't want to go out there and
kill each other and the ends of the
lances had Cornell's put on them again
to disperse the impact force on the
knights armor it's like a cast fist put
on well if you don't do that you have a
scene possibly like this and
historically that that could have
definitely happened so I'm a total Game
of Thrones geek and I love the show
however I have to give it our four
they you know utilize just that
connection with the horse without the
Stirrup the Stirrup didn't really come
into play until the Battle of Hastings
in 1066 a Roman Calvary it's great
Riders because they're basically rotting
just with that feel and connection
underneath them where the percherons are
now you know 17 18 19 hands tall
they would have never been that tall
they were a lot shorter back then as a
matter of fact they were more almost the
size of a large Pony to be honest with
you 14 to 15 hands
his horse was tripped Up Down the Horse
went and down down Hugo how does it feel
to uh to come off of your horse while
flying through the air is pretty easy
it's the sudden stop when you hit the
ground that really sucks just to be
honest with you he rolled uh so he was
fine it's a muddy muddy terrain there's
been times when I've you know come off
my horse that I've landed on my feet
next to the horse holding on to the
reins stay on your horse but if your
horse is going to go down uh it's best
for you to get clear of your horse
because you don't want that 1 500 to 2
000 pounds horse
body slamming on top of you my jousting
career I have very little injuries from
my full contact jousting career the more
injuries I've had are training horses
for the sport of Joe Osteen and you're
getting on a horse in a an outfit from
Battlestar Galactica Cylon you know I
mean like that that's going to freak a
horse out I'd give the whole scene a
definite eight
so you have two different styles of
jousting you have Heath Ledger
um you know with a targ shield and you
have
um his competitor coming down and full
plate harness uh more of a a you know
Northern Italian style where he had no
Shield
where
they were saying get it in the Cradle
get it in the Cradle before the Cradle
was the uret and on the ends of the
lances they'd have a small disc of wood
or
um a ring set in place to be able to
catch this a rat so when you bring that
Lance down the Lance will slide in and
lock into that eret and so it'll stop
the Lance from going any farther back so
all that pressure comes onto your body
and you're able to give that much more
of a forceful hit with your body to be
able to break those lances and
ultimately unhorse your opponents try
and hold on to 1 800 pounds of force I I
hate to admit this but I broke my hand
seven times
trying to learn how to give devastating
hits and I don't know how many times
that a bone has been sticking through my
thumb in an actual jousting competition
and even in this movie you see these
horses completely decked out but it's
deceiving some a lot of people think
well they're wearing that armor to
protect the horse well the horse was
never a Target as a matter of fact back
in that period of time if you struck
your opponent's horse you'd be stripped
of land and title why'd they have armor
well it was more of a a car show they
didn't want to bring their Volkswagen
they brought their Ferrari hey check me
out and that's that's what that horse
armor was for
remove your helmet
right the final blow of the Lance was
bent it onto my head where it smashed in
his helmet um and he can't get it off
still happened back then and still
happens today's modern time as well one
of my dear friends took a shot in the
helmet and spun his entire helmet around
breaking his nose so it looked like it
it looked like literally it spun his
head like a top of course we're having
problems getting it off because his
whole face was all smushed up in there
you even left the target's down here you
know often you do get hit in the head of
course Heath Ledger's helmet no person
in their right mind would have worn that
helmet you do not want the Lance to get
in towards your face this helmet you'll
see a lot of different designs uh this
is called a Sparrow's beak Helm it's
there because when you receive a direct
Lance hit
you don't want a flat surface like Heath
Ledger received in that hit where it
caved his helmet in it's very very
difficult to cave this style of helmet
in and that's where I use it for my for
my jousting career full contact is
probably one of the stupidest thing a
man could ever do I'd give it a seven
and a half
[Music]
the Goblins open up the door and they
charge down that's a true maneuver that
can easily happen and I'm knocking down
because they caught them at surprise and
you you take 10 guys and put them behind
each other and take speed a horse that
two thousand pounds or 1 500 pounds for
a lighter horse charging into that it's
a bowling ball knocking down bowling
ball pins so that the question is can
you keep up that inertia and keep on
going so the the initial knockdown will
knock the wind out he might not kill you
but it's the other 50 hundred thousand
two thousand three thousand horses
trampling over top of you just like
cutting grass on the Sunday afternoon
you're going to mow down what's in front
of you so very true and could easily
happen and uh it did happen you know
historically absolutely
[Music]
King field and uh you know kind of
wobbling off balance a little bit it
could be the fact that the actor wasn't
comfortable in the saddle it picking up
a weapon and wielding it on Horseback
again is is that much more attention to
the weapon and less attention on what
you're actually riding when I train
people how to joust I always tell them
from the hips down rides the horse from
the hips up
does the task so the upper body can stay
you know glued and have a good platform
to be able to wield that sword or couch
that Lance or you know spear that ring
or whatever your job entails on that
given specific day
all the Goblins this time prepped and
prepared with the long pull arms you
know locked down and locked in place a
truly historical defense against the
heavy horse charge
um to the extent that
they actually stopped a lot of the
knights would stop doing that heavy
horse charge because that horse was
worth so much to them if they actually
had to fight sometimes they Dismount and
run in and fight on foot and not take
their horse you can train a horse all
your life to do this one specific job
and all of a sudden it's it's go time
and the horse realizes it's really
stupid and he'd rather you just go and
fight yourself and he was going to go
back and hang out with the Sumpter they
had a lot of good historical elements in
there and a lot of good action that
could have been seen on a battlefield so
I actually give it as a seven
[Music]
so in this situation a loud bang would
just make the horse
run faster it's not going to know where
that's coming from it would shy more of
the motorcycles coming up beside it than
it would anything else it would not want
to be near the motorcycles
um but again in that scenario where you
have cars on left and right the only way
it really can go is forward so the horse
is steering himself at that point if you
have a super fast Thoroughbred you're
you're talking down a street like this
easily 35 miles an hour
it looks like Keanu Reeves did all of
his own stunt there you have to be in
great a great Rider to be able to do
that and he pulled it off you know you
could tell he added stunt saddle on they
had a really high pommel that he was
able to grab when he put his foot in the
strip to go to the side of the horse to
be able to you know shoot from the front
barrel of the chest in real life you
wouldn't have a pommel that high you
know in front of you to be able to grab
you would find that for stunt riders not
to say that a good equestrian can't just
on a western saddle be able to be able
to do that it was a really good stunt
very realistic and could could easily
happen I'd probably give it an eight
foreign
this whole scene is absolutely fantastic
back then they didn't have a green
screen or just CGI they knocked it out
of the park that is 100 percent what I
believe historically a chariot race
would have been like a lot of people
died in the in the chariot races it was
a very dangerous thing I drive a chariot
um the more horses you add the more
power and more dangerous it gets
chariots back in that time were were
pulled by one two three
Four Horses of course you see all these
you know cars doing drifting on tracks
well you know that's nothing because uh
we can do drifting with a horse and a
chariot it's amazing
those horses are connected by rains from
from the lead horses all the way back to
the driver sitting in the Chariot in the
rider's hands in this point he would
have a set for the left the left horse
is in the set for the right horses being
able to control that some Riders would
have every horse Reigns coming into his
hands and there is so much power and
force that those drivers to get those
chariots to stop because there really
was no breaks would often have to put
their feet up on the front of the
Chariot to be able to pull back with all
their might to be able to get those
horses to slow down in front of them and
no CGI no green screen that is
definitely a 10 for a chariot race in my
book
if you have a good riding ability and a
good horse you can do anything on top of
that horse how the rider steps off and a
flying y or you know it switches around
for a w because he comes back up around
the other way and sits back up on that
horse and once you form that partnership
with the horse again you can do
anything with that horse
cool I wish I was that good a lot of
trick riding there the the bow that they
have is is a mounted archery bow
um they use thumb release which is again
another you know tactic for mounted
archery so historically
a Mongolian Archer is not somebody you
want to meet in the back alley
absolutely not so yes it is difficult
but you have to realize that they've
been rotting
since birth I think it's a great scene
but I'm not going to say it can't be
done absolutely it can I'd give it a
nine
[Applause]
the style that they're doing is is
open field uh meaning that there's no
actual list they stopped having open
field Jose because the horses were
colliding into one another and they
didn't again want those injuries
happening to the horses these were
definitely war horses to have two horses
charging at one another
is something a normal horse just does
not do you know their flight fleeing
flight animals they are not turn and
charged down animals unless it's a mare
chasing off a stallion or another
stallion fighting for for Turf with
another stallion
the lances they could have done a better
job the lances you could tell have a tip
on them so there were a tournament Lance
it's it's a cost saving Factor
um and they put new tips on an actual
joust of War which would have been a
solid shaft and would have had the
pointed cornells like not the blunted
Cornell like or the flared Cornell they
would have had like points on them I'm
not sure who was teaching them how to
Jost but punching with your Lance like
that
not good you want to hold that Lance as
tight as you can to your body because
that's what's going to give that
strength you're not going to get
anything by throwing a punch except for
a broken wrist or a broken hand
so when you duck down the Lance also
tipped down and unfortunately killed
that horse this is the chess piece
for a horse the Patroll is what it's
called now again it would you know there
to protect the front of the horse's
chest it still gives enough room for the
horse to move its legs underneath but
behind this plate you know ultimately is
the horse's heart and that's where the
heart is and one of the vulnerable spots
uh in Warfare uh to strike to strike a
horse and that's why they protected it
immensely with these plates
[Music]
oh
this is a grief um and the thigh piece
is a queeze back in that time the French
had the best armor so it kind of carried
through in today's modern day
translation as well this piece right
here
this is you know would go on my left
side of my bottom leg but you notice
there's nothing on the inside well
there's nothing on the inside of my calf
because that's how I control and feel my
horse and the reason this is open is so
my calf the inside of my leg can feel
the barrel of my horse and be able to
give cues whether it be left right
forward or back man if they could have
not punched with the lances and had a
solid wooden Lance it would have been
indefinite 10 but I'm going to have to
give it a nine
explosive powders
As Weapons or distractions is
[Music]
foreign
go
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
uh
you know
this is
area
that is
foreign
Orange
[Music]
um
huh
YouTube
his name
foreign
over here
tonight
Focus
ninja ninja
today
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
awesome
hey man come on everyone is
where are you
[Laughter]
um
foreign
[Music]
snare
almost unrivaled
receipts universe
young race
is
foreign
[Music]
Academy we use the indigenous fighting
Arts of the Philippines also known as
Kali Arness or escrima today we're going
to look at some of the movies that have
popularized Filipino fighting Arts
he has to be very careful the situation
even though they're in a public setting
this is a Close Quarters combat fight
this is them getting very very close to
each other and him not having a lot of
time to respond to the blade
the Winter Soldier throwing the blade
and catching it seems very flashy it
doesn't seem to be quite useful it's not
very realistic more seemingly for the
movie effect
and then there's a moment where the
blade is actually coming at the Winter
Soldier right there so in that moment
where he's trying to grab the arm
underneath we wouldn't recommend that
kind of response so the reason being is
that the hand that's holding the blade
is again with that ice pick grip the
blade is coming in right here on the
face and we would encourage students to
get on this side of the blade on the
outside or try to bring that arm another
way
it it really makes you think about your
ability to learn these kinds of
techniques and the truth is that it
really depends on the student it depends
on you know the style of fighting that
you're learning
um we would have to give Captain America
a 5 out of ten just because it wasn't
too realistic
oh
as exciting and great as it is
Uma Thurman shows exceptional reflexes
maybe super power ones we would
recommend in survival arts training is
the way that we step out of the
situation with 45 degrees and we try to
be on the outside of the body and the
outside of that bladed Edge
so we're seeing Vivica actually stab and
try to kind of like hit in these broken
strikes but never actually fully commits
to full fluid strikes which would make
her movements a lot more realistic and
believable and effective in trying to
kill the main character the proper way
of striking would be to do fluid strikes
whether you're doing it with a Long
Blade a stick a short blade and so
you'll be you know moving in a more
effective means and also not wasting any
movement
so basically when you're holding a knife
you're going to be looking at
um two main grips so we're going to be
looking at this very common kind of
night grip which moves in this kind of
motion and so you'll see here that
Vivica is actually using this night grip
okay and then you'll see in comparison
that Uma Thurman is holding it in this
knife grip which is the ice pick grip
also very effective so these are two of
the best knife grips that you want to
understand and also be able to respond
to
you know you can hold it in one hand
switch to the other hand switch back you
know depending on your agility so the
idea is that you're never stuck with
that one movement or that one grip
you're always trying to figure out in
response to counter the other person so
our critique of vivica's movements are
that they're a little bit exaggerated
and not quite real so we're seeing a lot
of wasted movement here and a lot of
openings for her to also be attacked for
this kind of movie we would have to give
a score of 4 out of ten but it is a lot
of fun and we are big fans of Kill Bill
at first he has no weapon fighting
against multiple weapons and somehow
manages to get a weapon so that's great
that he was able to actually disarm and
it shows the different kinds of weapons
that we actually trained in colleagues
so you know we work with single sticks
and double sticks and in this particular
film they're working with batons a baton
is just another form of stick work
oh
so having a baton and being able to use
that with the fluid strikes with against
multiple ones is actually recommended we
can trace the roots of these systems as
early as the 12th century or the 15th
century when the Spanish colonized the
Philippines and a lot of systems are
even traced to 1898 when the American
Colonization period during these times
weapons were confiscated and banned by
the colonial forces so indigenous
peoples creatively hid
in different ways so for example the
blade was taken away we replaced it with
a stick and the stick represents the
blade and so that's why we always train
with the stick first we also need the
movements of the fighting Arts within
dance
okay so right here where Liam Neeson
actually takes the stick off of his
opponent where he disarms and uses it
you wouldn't want to step into that
weapon or close the distance unless you
were absolutely being offensive on the
way in when you're thinking about going
against opponents with a weapon or
attackers with a weapon you would never
want to turn your back to that person
the right way would be to come into the
attacker being offensive you know with a
an attack to the face and an elbow to
the face anything that is coming in to
to do some damage in order to get close
to that weapon and then disarm it
clearly Liam has also trained in a lot
of martial arts in Kali and other
martial arts because you can see it in
his movements we would give him a 7 out
of 10 but taking away some of the points
because of the technical errors that we
notice
the knife is coming and Jason is
responding he's parrying here he is also
maintaining control by staying close to
the attacker so in a close quarter
situation every movement every second
counts and as you can see from Jason
Bourne's movement every touch is
offensive and that's very much in the
Kali style this is that that famous
scene where he uses a pen and it's an
everyday object that is really quite
dangerous and can be utilized Just Like
a Knife a key can be used a shoe a
magazine rolled up a newspaper these can
be very powerful weapons
he was trying really hard to kind of get
that knife out of that situation for us
and Kali we would just break the arm or
we'd step around to the outside a little
bit more
foreign
right there we see just a quick movie
camera mistake or camera cheating thing
here the opponent actually throws a left
hook but Jason suddenly catches his
right arm and tries to disarm that so
for The Bourne Identity because of its
great fight scene we would probably give
this score a 9 out of 10. only docking a
point for a mistake actually that we
noticed here
you see that the woman fighting is
getting cut Elsa and then the man is
also getting up but yet they still
continue to fight even though they're
getting kind of slashed in different
parts of their arm their back
some of the knife attacks that are
coming in seem a bit wasted a trained
knife fighter or someone who's trained
in the Arts would be more aware to
attack more of the vital zones so you
know cutting the neck or cutting the
arteries
um go for going through some of the kill
shots rather than just you know cutting
in random spots that that won't stop the
attacker from attacking our goal would
be to move on the outside of the body in
order to capture the knife hand or kind
of get around the knife hand and go for
that that back of the neck shot so this
the area around the neck or this whole
neck area is very vulnerable as a Kill
Zone that's why we teach for example to
have your hands up protect your neck you
know keep your eyes and your hands
moving and keep them available so that
if there are attacks and you know you're
able to kind of move around you have
elbows you have you have things to
utilize that are your own body as
weapons but the technique that's being
demonstrated here not so much
there's few moments that happened here
were Elsa actually climbs up on her
attacker so there's a moment where she
steps on his leg in order to cut him on
the other side and then does it again in
a more exaggerated form for her and
kills and then again climbs all the way
up here we go using the leg lifting
herself up there seems to be a lot of
time here and the person is holding a
blade and not using it there were a few
shots where
technically that person should have been
dead already
because I saw a knife shot to the neck
and then suddenly you know they're able
to back up create space and come in
again we would probably give this a
score of 6 out of ten just because it's
exciting to see a woman you know
fighting so powerfully but at the same
time just doesn't seem so realistic
this scene is great
you know you can see a lot of technique
here there's a lot of resourcefulness
being shown clearly a lot of Kali
training and we see a lot of
similarities here in the film to the
training that we teach
you know he picks up a very
small kind of like personal hygiene item
this can be very deathly when used in
the correct way especially with that
knife grip that he used and so Craig
actually used a knife grip just like
this like an ice pick and is you know
jabbing and stabbing his opponent with
that weapon very effective
that's another thing that distincts
Filipino fighting Arts from other
fighting Arts is the footwork and is the
stancework you know a lot of fighting
Arts are actually very linear they may
be something like karate for example
you're moving you know kind of like in
this position of of linear movement but
in a Filipino fighting style our
movement is always based on the triangle
or triangular kind of motion and so our
footwork would reflect that in side
stepping you know to the side or
stepping 45 degrees which Craig really
demonstrates for the effectivity of the
technique and the movements Quantum of
Solace we get an 8 out of 10.
this is a fantastic scene
um first and foremost it is great
because it gives credit to the Filipino
culture where this knife came from so
the bali song is another name for the
butterfly knife which originated here in
the Philippines it actually came from a
region in Luzon called Batangas and it
is a butterfly knife because of the way
that it opens up like a butterfly and
has double edged blades on each side so
it's very very dangerous
that's probably something that you first
learned when you learn while these song
is how to open and close and so it's
very very you know exciting and fun
there is moments of where she's using
the blade to actually tap or hit on the
body that is quite realistic smaller
caliber version of what design uh Eugene
Stoners Arrington now Kali is for
everyone it's especially useful in
situations of survival because of the
way that we are able to respond to a
weapons attack even without a weapon
it's particularly useful for women and
children or smaller folks to protect
against a larger attacker our family
system is called pikiti tersha Kali and
it originates from the Western visayas
of the Philippines and this blade
culture has been protecting the family
since 1898 and even traces its roots to
more than 2 000 years ago we would
definitely give this a 9 out of ten just
because we love the technique that Chloe
is doing but we would like to see a
little more offensive with the knife
itself
true
we have someone coming in with the
straight grip and we have someone coming
in with what looks like a Karambit which
is coming on the on the back side of
that bleed
when you get real real close to the
weapon the weapon then becomes rendered
useless which is the point sometimes
right like sometimes you need to step
into that that weapon hand or get close
offensively in order to take control of
that weapon or you need to find a way to
distract and knock the senses in other
ways in order to get out of that
situation so very intense Close Quarters
situation with blades but also very
yeah I would just say very interesting
you know when it comes to strength and
size it doesn't really matter when it
comes to the bleed so you know the blade
is The Equalizer here because the other
person fighting may be smaller or you
know not as strong it doesn't mean that
they're not as effective with the use of
a knife
you can always throw elbows and use the
elbow as a weapon so he's grabbing and
kneeing and hitting over the head when
he could easily just cut that hand that
he already has in his hand in his power
so that was technically a moment where
we would say isn't very realistic and is
a little more exaggerated for camera
there's like a big open swing and
they're extending the fight where they
don't need to
those are usually in movies you'll see
like total Destruction and chaos and and
collateral damage and collateral murder
but in this case you know they kind of
stop and wait for everyone to pass and
they get right back into it so it's it's
kind of funny probably give it about a 7
out of 10 because they did great you
know with the with the knife grips but
technically speaking there were a few
errors that we noticed that kept the
fight scene a little too long that it
had to be
so right away we're seeing a very
familiar Filipino martial arts double
stick drill one of the first things or
one of the early things that you would
learn when you're learning how to
utilize a double stick or double sticks
as a weapon so this is a great drill we
often call this upper six or Heaven Six
the actors are not properly chambering
their weapons so that's something that
wouldn't be seen in a real Filipino
martial arts training when you have the
sticks every time you strike you chamber
so the idea is that you're always
bringing the stick back before hitting
again
is a bit of a camera cheating angle
that's happening so the way that we do
this particular drill is with a lot of
footwork you'll see us you know moving
with the double sticks and moving
um forward and back exchanging um feet
and moving around in a circle most
importantly at first glance you might
think oh well they are moving around in
a circle until you look carefully and
realize that the actors are actually not
doing the footwork and it's the camera
itself that's moving around in a circle
they do the drill and one of the guys
hits the other one if you're doing the
drill correctly you wouldn't get hit
because you continuously be doing the
drill so that's another thing that we
notice like oh you know that doesn't
seem too realistic because they stopped
why did they stop we would probably give
it a 4 out of 10 for realism
it's one of the greatest movies and it
definitely demonstrates a ton of Kali
work I mean Denzel here is using a Long
Blade he's fighting against multiple
opponents he's using all kinds of
slashes circular movements lateral
strikes he's thrusting
he even puts the blade down at one point
and then brings it back out so this is
really a great demonstration of
extensive coffee training um I do know
that Denzel did train with Jeffrey Monda
at the Dan and santovic Academy in Los
Angeles to develop these skills Jeff and
Marta does train at the Innocence
Academy where we've trained with our
Grandmaster we've had the pleasure of
meeting Jeff we're talking great classic
choreographers here
he is countering every single attack
that is coming his way that's the
mindset of Kali that instead of you know
moving around and trying to go after
each person if you stay in one place and
wait for the attack to come but be able
to move the feet and the blade in an
effective way then you're able to
respond very effectively this is a great
example of not having to do too much but
also doing a lot in that one space that
you're combined in this weapon looks
like a machete a machete here in the
Philippines would be called the bolo you
know it would be considered an everyday
blade something that would normally be
used to you know cut sugar cane or to
you know engage in farming or fishing or
building your house so it seems like you
know just an everyday kind of Blade but
the way that and and the length of it so
the length of it is is quite long it's
considered a long wait range weapon and
because of that it can be very effective
with fighting against multiple opponents
there's even a scene in the beginning of
the movie where he's on a highway patrol
and someone tries to attack and he kind
of just slices the handoff in a swift
single motion that is the kind of
movement that we are trained to also
develop we have to give it a 10 out of
10. excellent technique great execution
Gotta Love Lucy Lou
you know she comes storming in with
power with confidence and she's got not
one but two weapons so you're seeing a
lot of exciting movement here
she's attacking different levels high
low you know arms heads feet it's just
such a great scene uh and an example of
how a double weapon can be used against
multiple opponents especially in the
distance that she's maintaining with
them
that every
every these people are fully padded in a
ton of gear because we would doubt that
those batons would do that much damage
to these trained men that are all padded
up with that kind of gear and also the
fact that everyone here that she's
fighting against has a major weapon they
have a gun and they're not using it
they're just kind of being thrown on the
floor no one's picking it up
because she's utilizing both of the
weapons
um she's extending her arms and she's
moving in full circles you know that's
very effective that's the kind of stuff
that we teach
um to be able to you know maneuver for
one opponent to the other you know
hitting Folks at the same time she has
good motion range of motion with her
weapons she Chambers them brings them
back to the body hits again you know
multiple attacks here against that last
person you know a lot of circular
movements the realism of the scenario
we'd actually give this probably a six
out of ten
um just because we think Lucy was doing
great work just doesn't seem so
realistic compared to her opponents